[Music]
our next guest is a talented comedian
who can be seen at the vic theatre in
chicago on sunday april 29th and at the
balboa theater in san diego on saturday
july 14th please welcome the very funny
bo burnham
[Music]
thanks so much everybody
thank you so much it's an honor to be
here
oh god
it's embarrassing
he meant to knock the water over yeah
yeah all thought it was an accident but
he meant to knock the water over yeah
yeah yeah heart is a lie nothing is real
so guys i've been working on my uh
i'm working on my heckler comebacks
that's sort of a sign of a real polished
good stand-up comedian's ability to come
back to a heckler and i've been working
on a few lines uh thought i could try
some out on you uh someone give me like
a you suck
hey man
so i was i ate a uh
i ate a hot dog for breakfast the other
day and uh afterwards i felt like this
i couldn't control my stools okay i uh
grow up
there's a creepy old man fishing in the
park and the only problem is he tied a
candy bar to the end of his line he's
trying to catch a kid
[Applause]
walking between the microphones
is really awkward i'd like to do some
poems for you guys um
some poems we can sit we can think and
then uh
get the giggles out now and then um
pages are blankets theater uh
there's a poem by a dog roses are gray
violets are a different shade of grey
let's go chase cars
no one understands me
she said in a timid whisper as she
combed her beard
me
with my strange choice of adjectives
you with your muscular teeth and
clockwise vagina
you're incomparable like a
i said no to drugs once
i looked a bag of weed right in the face
and like a loving but stern father i
said no
i was really high so
this is a poem about uh beauty
and about self-image and about uh
transformation
martha was ugly like a shaven baboon so
she wrapped herself up in a curtain
cocoon
and after a week she finally emerged she
smelled like wet garbage what a psycho
when i walk into a party you think i was
one of those long straight tetris pizzas
because everyone's just like oh yeah
this guy's here great
and i'll leave you with this um it's
been a pleasure being here this is a
story for children
the squares lived happily
in their square houses
in their square towns
in their square yards
one day a family of circles moved in
from the west
get out of here roundies
shout out to one of the squares
why
said one of the circles
because this is a metaphor for racism
thank you very much
uh
good night thank you
that's great
hey vote vernon ladies and gentlemen